you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman chess calm
right now and I just got paired up with
the best triple Eight's this is a little
bit of a slower time control five - so
let's see what we could do with this
let's go with mmm yeah let's go at c4
it's gonna go d4 but I play the Queen's
Gambit maybe too much okay throw in a
quick check and scoop that pawn up let's
go for that
so with that they've given me a
two-to-one majority in the center so
I'll look to try and put that to use now
I don't have to take that pawn just yet
um if I do the knight is no longer
pinned delaying its capture might be an
idea because black may want to play e5
so if I hold this pin for a moment the
one pawn black has can't be played in
the center just yet
however I think I still want to snip
this pawn because eventually they're I
mean they're still useful moves Knight
f6 and eventually moves like a six then
b5 can force my hand anyhow so Knight b6
is a bit early I think at least black
isn't you're going to be getting this
pawn to e5 or isn't really shooting for
that hmm I wonder about fee and cuddling
or Knight c3 d4 come to mind I'm gonna
play it in a bit more of a restrained
fashion I'm gonna go with listen I
actually I'll start with this remain
flexible I was gonna play g3 but I'll
still leave my options open maybe I'll
go with the d4 bishop bow III or g3
Bishop g2 and kind of like a reverse
dragon structure the white side d3 g3
Bishop g2 a5
that weakens b5 okay um huh well I think
I want to shift gears and not go in for
the fee and keto I think I still could
but I play it however on d4 Bishop g4 is
a little bit annoying yeah let's let's
go with this I was thinking on d4 one of
the strikes black would go for is c5 but
that's that would really be a tremendous
weakness of the b5 square so let's
follow through swing the back completely
around g3 Bishop g2 and I think these
are okay so I think these next few moves
are going to be non-confrontational
however night before you know to start
reacting and finding a good square for
my queen this is interesting okay I
think I could squeeze a little bit more
out of my deep on now I mean why not
play up two squares black isn't stopping
me from doing that there's no fear
Bishop takes Knight and Queen take Sundy
anymore so might as well put this Center
to use I have a two-to-one we're Geordi
in the center let's get on with that
yeah I don't I don't see why not
a knight takes I'll take with my pawn
because I have to watch over e4 I'll let
spree move that is he gonna go to b4 on
b4 night before I have now a new square
available I think black is wise to
exchange pieces some pieces because I do
have a space advantage right now
an ideal pawn center so decision time
Knight d4 Knight takes Knight I'm pretty
sure you have to get the move back you
know
okay so let's recapture building the
center they're striking b5 is a glaring
weakness
can I take advantage of that I should be
able to I really should there ought to
be one comes to mind I don't want to
play this just yet let's get some faster
moves in I don't want to play off the
increment I've been doing that too much
this can be difficult to defend now okay
how that square covered they're
releasing that tension my queen though
has some new squares this is uh that's a
problem Queen c6 you have to play Bishop
d7 and I could take this pawn oh what's
the big idea there don't quite
understand that move Queen c6 Bishop d7
Queen takes we exchange Knight takes e4
Knight e5 and I mean that can't be good
can it what's going on with this that
seems so weakening just gonna go for
this variation even if I'm not winning
material have an active position at
least they're still uncashed so yeah
let's let's follow through with this
so Knight takes e4 Knight e5 and yeah my
Brooks okay it's hurting that my first
home hmm okay not sure where my rip
belongs let's play
I don't know here I want to stay out of
a night move with tempo okay so let's
follow through it there's I'm under two
minutes it's got a lot more tactical
early on here under 20 minutes our under
20 moves about two minutes Knights hit
darks for LightScribe Bishop's hit if
they're not careful Bishop a3 and
there's no castling f5 is just an
incredibly weakening move Knight g6 also
take the light square bishop this is one
of those positions where there's going
to be a lot of good options I think for
me and I think I need to pick one quick
and just go with it be really practical
I'm already think about f5 taking the
night taking LightSquared bishop and
hunting down this light this doubled
pawn it's a simple way to play an f5
take the bishop rook check that's
another one because the king and the
bishop can't block because of Bishop f4
rook c1 and I think there's too much
fuel on that pinned piece on c7 ok this
night is in a pin first and foremost
they have to do something about that how
can it be ignore it okay alright let's
take my own advice play quick here throw
a check
that's a super-duper active rook this
Knight is still in a pen I could scoop
up that pun it's my first thought no
reason to take that night he's not
bothering me he's in a pin Bishop here
Wow
how is black surviving this let's stay
on the 7th for one and I really just
want to take that night now what else is
there I have pressure enough to let's
take this guy and mmm rook to e1 yeah
let's do that
enric f8 I'll play Bishop here and I
Neifi on it on e5 I'll just take the
pawn on e4 this must be winning so let's
just stay head on the clock here hmm
okay let's remove their most active
piece I'm Bishop f4 rook see - it's a
bit of a pain this rook is enormous
rook something was somewhere here I have
a check and there goes the rook so I'm
up upon no I'm not
feels like I'm up upon I have two active
rooks should be winning let's see that's
just a big problem isn't it I guess they
just missed that probably resigning here
that got a bit complicated we're going
to have a look at this one with a stock
fish and see where there are some
improvements there my initial thought
you know before I even touch this game
with stock fish my initial thought is
that Knight b6 is maybe I don't know I'm
thinking e5 first to submit a pawn in
the center Knight b6
I don't know this opening but it
certainly kind of struck me as slightly
odd that was one of them it does gain
tempo against the Queen but
she's kind of quite glad to reside on
the C 2 square and the other one was a 5
and the H 6 move it seemed a little bit
slow these till I got a big center but
ok yeah let's quickly review it here
I'll bring a stock fish on board and
let's see what it has to say ok let's
see where we can both improve so far so
good it does suggest to you 5 here
computer but Knight b6 not bad it's
still fine
I don't know big shift so far let's see
yeah my other idea was d4 here doesn't
have a problem with d4 or e4 many
options you know with my opponent not
yet establishing a pawn in the center I
have two Center pawns
d4 e4 g 3 but as mentioned in the game
they're the two approaches I had in mind
d4 bishop out III it's a bit more solid
but going with a fee in Quetta that
can't be bad to their bad either so g3
and he big shifts what was missed has
around this half pun advantage yeah
these turned out to be a bit slow sage 6
move out really sure the intention there
shouldn't be some fear of a pin against
g5 I mean as it stands right now there's
not even huh I don't know there's not
even some threat of a piece going here
that I'm not sure what the intention is
behind h6 hmm ok was calling for a rook
d1 but this is fine here before I have
the center yeah I mean it's already
liking the white position by a lot of
Hahn advantage I didn't really have to I
didn't really do much
you know just grabbing the the c4 pawn
and running away and developing
naturally
it's kind of just helped by my opponent
a little by little and see when it got a
bit tactical here I have this Center b6
huh does not like Queen c6 is the top
move okay
95 immediately huh that's what it's
calling for and on Bishop to d7 and just
to cover that c6 square scooping up the
bishop Knight takes what would be wrong
with Queen takes and I just dropping b6
okay anything wrong with Queen c6
no still okay Bishop is there okay so so
far so good this is fine Bishop back
there yeah I guess it taking the pawn
immediately isn't good because of the
same move in the game 95 this is
basically the desired square when you
have this configuration Fein cutted
Bishop the Knights in his way you want
to play here anyhow knock out two birds
with one stone and prove the knight
position la the bishop to finally see so
okay this is still holding upon
advantage did it ever slip rook b1
anything wrong with rip b3 there's a
tempo type move with Bishop a4 but if
black isn't able to scoop this pawn up
successfully then it's just clearly
better for white knight takes 95 and
yeah that's just a game loser
a5 and there's no holding this rook b7
instead of taking but this is still fine
takes rook check and there is no Bishop
c7 I'm pretty sure right on this they're
saying first take here and then chip
away at this pinned piece they can only
at most defend the bishop with two
pieces and now this is collapsing taking
advantage of the pinned piece but you
know the rook on the seventh did it not
like that capture I'll rook e1 instead
that's interesting hmm another one being
suggested now is Richard to a three yeah
I mean it's not bad what I did scooping
up upon but maybe maybe another frame of
mind to be in in such a position is
instead of first looking to grab some
material which is exactly what this move
is doing look to first mobilize all
pieces I still have a rook and a bishop
that are not contributing so that's why
we're seeing blink up there at least for
a moment or two rook e1 and Bishop to a3
getting these other pieces working this
makes a lot more sense as soon as you
see it strike at the knight strike at
the e6 pawn indirectly or another way to
even look at it is to eliminate the one
piece that's in your own position the
most or the best piece for black in this
position but there'll be plenty of
options from here plenty plenty of good
choices but kids into that gets into
playing with a good technique playing in
a way where you don't give your opponent
any sort of counter play making it as
simple as possible so it's still holding
an advantage here Bishop takes d4 taking
the knight is good you know it's not
really much it's fine with this move I
was a bit fearful of this and rook here
but actually I was still not even
realizing that I have this move at that
moment but - either way eliminating this
active piece and then there's just
nothing to do what's best here rook c1
King g2 and then rip to f8 these are not
happy moves it takes e4 and unhook here
there's a check here and yeah this is
going to be completely winning takes
takes and then rip to h8 they would get
this I'd probably even look for a
different way to do it but this is of
course completely winning the rug gets
behind the passed pawn soon and
that'll be GG but as a played-out rook
c4 and I guess they just overlooked that
skewer anyhow a pretty short game even
though it was a 5-2 it got a pretty
tactical the middle game there are right
out of the opening but as usual feel
free to leave any comments in the
comment section below to this video and
I'll catch you in the next one that's
all for now take care bye